it's that time of the year again here's
our guide to surviving the holidays
according to the movies step 1 pick the
right tree there's only one way to get
into the holiday spirit drinking I mean
decorating for some that means lighting
the menorah for others that means
finding a squirrel infested tree but
don't feel you need to venture into the
wilderness there are plenty of tree lots
with perfectly good trees just be
careful of those sketchy ones because
you'll probably end up in a gunfight
instead get a tree from somewhere you
trust and wait a second that tree is
attacking that lady now the second
thought maybe don't get a tree step 2
travel safe holiday travel is always
hectic so to ensure your safety always
travel with a buddy avoid those trucks
and snowplows and when all else fails
use a jetpack step 3 be vigilant always
keep your guard up during the holiday
season because you never know when those
pesky gremlins and penguins are going to
ruin the holiday party you can stay safe
by sticking with your pals and you might
want to upgrade your home security
system we recommend a standard package
that includes swinging paint cans tar
hidden nails blowtorches fiery doorknobs
sharp ornaments feathers falling bricks
faulty generators lead pipe staple guns
a tank maybe even a spider for good
measure step 4 beware of those bad
Santa's everyone gets stressed out
during the holidays even father
Christmas avoid a Santa Claus who
doesn't have a twinkle in his eye and
the ones who smell like distilleries
instead of peppermint step 5 express
your love look the holidays can be an
emotional time it can ruin families
friendships and Ben Affleck's early film
career but the holiday spirit can heal
those wounds so remember to tell the
people closest to you how you really
feel no we're not looking straight in
the eye I don't want to tell them what a
cheap lying no-good rotten four-flushing
lowlife snake looking dirt-eating inbred
there's so much joy to be had in the
holiday season so try not to get lost in
all the stress and remember the greatest
gift that you can give is far more
special than any TV or piece of jewelry
it's love and a PlayStation 4 there it's
basically a tie between the
I'm going to go with playstation 4